okay today I'm going to talk to you
about belt transects so I'm gonna right
underneath the purpose of belt transects
it's to find out how organisms are
distributed across a gradient and
explain what that means in just a second
across a gradient so first of all an
organism is a living thing so we might
be interested to see how living things
change across this thing called a
gradient and what a gradient is
essentially a change in an abiotic
factor so an abiotic factor is a non
living factor so we might be interested
to see how let's say light intensity
affects the growth of plants we might be
interested in looking at how the amount
of water and the soil effects that go
with a plant or the temperature we're
basically how living a nonliving thing
affects the distribution of a particular
organism a particular living thing so
I'm just going to imagine here I'm just
drawing a very simple diagram of a river
so imagine we have this river flowing
here now what we might want to do is we
might want to see how does but the
basically the further we get away from
the river how does this affect the
distribution of organisms so the abiotic
factor in this particular case that
we're looking at would be the level of
water that we find in the soil so the
first thing that we do is we get a tape
measure and we set it up because so it
goes away from our particular starting
point of interest this could be a river
it could be a the end of a line of trees
in a forest what whatever we want so
what we need to do is this we use a bit
of equipment called a quadrat now all a
quadrat is is it's a square frame that
allows us to do we put it down on the
ground
it allows us to count the organisms of
interest within the different gaps so
we'll be counting to see how many there
are so what we need to do is essentially
we're interested to see how does the
level of water in the soil affect the
number of plants let's say we're looking
at daisies the further we get away from
the river so what we do is we have a
starting point which would be right here
where we put our quadrat down what we
then want to do is we want to reposition
our quadrat at equal intervals slowly
going away from our particular point of
interest so let's say for example if
that one's at zero meters this one's at
two meters then four meters then six
meters then eight meters so every single
time what we're going to do is when we
put down the quadrat we're looking at
two things first of all we need to count
the number of organisms that are within
that quadrat and secondly we need to use
some kind of probe or sensor in order to
figure out the kind of how much of that
abiotic factor we have so in this
particular instance what we're going to
be using is a water sensor to see how
much water is in the soil here here here
here and here and Counting how many
plants or how many daisies we have in
each of these different quadrants as
well now different abiotic factors we
could investigate we could be looking at
the effect of light intensity so we
might need a light meter at each of
these settings to read how bright it is
we could also use a temperature probe to
see the temperatures at each of these
places so after we've done the belt
transect at once we just need to repeat
it a couple of times in order to collect
more data so again exactly the same
technique but this time a little bit
further along so here's my five quadrats
that I put down again and then I need to
repeat it at least three times and each
time are putting down the quadrat I'm
counting the number of organisms or this
case daisies that I'd have at each of
these intervals again evenly spread even
the distance so once I've done that what
I can do is I find my average number if
I take the mean number of plants for
these three so I add up the number of
organisms found in each of these three
and in this case because there's three
of them I divide by three I'd do the
same for the abiotic factors so I find
the reading on my water sensor and I
find the average also the mean value for
these three once I've collected all the
data I can hopefully draw a conclusion
to see how does the level of water
affect the distribution of daisies along
a belt transect and that's basically it
thank you